So there,
there's,
there's a whole lot of them,
75 percent of medical costs stem from
behavioral and cultural issues over
eating,
eating too much corn syrup,
smoking,
lack of exercise,
the basics,
the absolute basics are causing
tremendous cost in the system and
tremendous misery among the people who
have these conditions,
helping people understand their role in
their own health,
helping people move through a mental
space where they actually participate in
making their health better,
which ends up producing costs for their
companies,
for their insurance companies is what we
need to use this technology to do.
And lots of people might respond to the
ability to earn money by keeping
yourself healthy.
But some people might not.
Some people might only respond to other
motivations like losing money or social
pressure or
entertainment or,
um,
uh,
being in the know,
being helpful to others.
If you give someone an opportunity to be
helpful to others with your condition,
you see their health improved
dramatically for some personality types.
And our last company tickle,
we had 100 million registered users.
20 billion questions answered.
We had five phds on staff or on the
psychology of your personality and were
you working on sort of taking that,
that understanding about human
motivations and creating a set of
experiences which address the seven or
eight main motivation types which apply
to seven or eight different personality
types,
is gonna start to deepen our ability to
help people move through behavioral
changes they need to make to really
change their health and the costs of,
of their health,
of maintaining their health.
And so that's,
that's one of the things that we're
trying to do.
The,
the main costs come from diabetes,
heart disease,
obesity and asthma and allergies.
Those are the sort of main low hanging
fruits.
That's where if you look at where your
costs are coming from,
that's where they're coming from.
And you know,
diabetes is an epidemic in this kind of
88 percent of people have diabetes at
this point.
Um,
that's,
that's a major cost center.
So,
uh,
going after those diseases with these
new methodologies.
You know,
we've tried a disease management in the
past,
but it's generally been only going after
one personality type,
which is a nurse calls you twice a week
to berate you into maintaining your
health.
That works for some people but only
works for one personality type.
You need to apply many more tools to
getting people to change their behavior
and you need to deploy them in a much
more cost effective way,
which having an expensive nurse called
twice a week to the whole population is
pretty expensive way to do it.
And,
and so those are models that have
failed,
but there are many more models to try
and some of them are going to work over
the next five or 10 years.
And so that's what Med ped is as a
platform for trying out all these
different ideas and then capturing the
stats about what's working and then
iterating on that and,
and focusing people on the things that
are actually working,
evidenced based,
sort of behavioral change.
Uh,
and,
and that's,
that's where we're going.
Another,
another big cost center is a
misdiagnosis.
So in your local area,
you're going to have a physician
diagnose you and they may or may or not,
may or may not have the uptodate
information about
how to diagnose someone with these
sayings.
It's estimated that up to upwards of 40
percent of serious cancer cases are
misdiagnosed.
Not that you don't have lung cancer,
it's just what type of lung cancer and
the stage you're at.
It could be misdiagnosed,
which causes you to have the wrong drugs
with the wrong program for taking those
drugs at the wrong treatments.
And if it's 40 percent,
that's an incredible cost to the person
to be misdiagnosed and an incredible
cost to the system to have to treat them
for five or six months in the wrong way
before they actually get to the proper
treatment.
So that's another way that Med ped can
help is by processing the information,
uh,
more effectively,
and having the most up to date stuff
available to everyone,
including your local physician who can
then tap into that knowledge base and
help,
uh,
help that physician diagnose you
properly.
More often than not.